oui bonjour c'est Cécile de France pour
France 24
il est venu présenter Bonnard pierre et
Marthe un film de Martin Provost alors
c'est une histoire d'amour passionnante
ce deux êtres indissociable l'un de
l'autre Pierre Bonnard se peintre qu'on
connaît s'amuse c'était Marthe et je
pense que sans elle dans sa vie il ne
serait pas devenu Pierre Bonnard et
Marthe sans lui sans cet homme amoureux
qu'il a aimé passionnément et avec
tellement de dévouement je pense qu'elle
serait morte
c'est vrai que quand on collabore avec
des réalisateurs des réalisatrices
on est un peu la sensation effectivement
de d'être une muse le temps d'un
tournage et moi c'est une sensation que
j'aime beaucoup d'être au service en
fait d'un univers d'un artiste que je
respecte que j'admire et d'être là pour
pour raconter une histoire avec lui avec
elle
j'ose pas te redire mais bon peut-être
Cédric Capy je peux être Xavier
giannolis j'espère qu'il me considère un
petit peu comme une de leurs muses
alors moi je me considère pas du tout
comme une militante je crois beaucoup en
la puissance émotionnelle de l'être
humain au cerveau émotionnel c'est à
dire que nous à travers les choix de nos
personnages le choix des films qu'on
défend pour lesquels on se barre on
envoie des messages aux gens à l'opinion
publique puisque finalement on a aussi
cette fonction-là de faire réfléchir
mais c'est surtout par l'émotion je
pense qu'on peut bouger les choses
ce festival de Cannes représente d'abord
plein plein de souvenirs merveilleux des
moments incroyables que ce soit la
montée des marches que soit la rencontre
avec des gens fascinants que vous avez
l'occasion de croiser dans un ascenseur
ou dans un escalier et puis surtout le
partage de d'être entre gens passionnés
de cinéma pouvoir échanger d'avoir cette
passion commune c'est quand même c'est
quand même merveilleux
petite anecdote comme ça qui me vient au
hasard c'est c'était Jean Rochefort dans
un ascenseur donc et où il m'a fait un
compliment merveilleux donc je me
souviendrai toute ma vie
mais je vais pas le dire
merci